hey guys today we're gonna talk about
eight emotional eating tips so number
one avoid certain environments where you
know food is going to be displayed like
at the bakery don't hang out at the
bakery certain social events where you
know there's going to be a lot of junk
food and candies and cookies avoid those
environments okay very important
same thing with restaurants the first
thing they come to bring people is the
the bread okay so just make sure you
tell the waiter don't bring the bread or
the desserts okay because they they
really push these sweets on everyone
vitamin b1 is crucial for handling
stress and feelings of you're feeling
down it brings people up
nutritional yeast you can get it in
tablets it's very very important because
we're talking about emotional eating
we're talking about either stress or
maybe anxiety or depression right b1 is
vital and the problem is consuming the
sugar will deplete your b1 and create
those sensations it's kind of like a
never-ending trap where you're consuming
the junk you depleted to b1 you want it
more you consume it you deplete b1 and
it keeps going okay number three sleep
more very very important to focus on the
sleep because people that don't sleep
tend to crave it more they tend to eat
more foods when they're not really that
hungry so their appetite is higher and
they're going to be more stressed number
four if it's if it's related to your
menstrual cycle then take some seek help
or there's a product called estrogen
balance I put a link down below that
will help stabilize your cycle but
iodine and other factors will help
balance estrogen because this is a real
big problem it kind of puts you in a
state that's not yourself you're
irritable moody and of course you're
going to eat to help get relief number
five
fix the blood sugar issues you've
probably been watching my videos but
even if you haven't you need to start
watching the ones on keto and in a
minute fasting because unless that blood
sugar is handled boy it's going to be
really impossible to get
rid of the hunger and the cravings but
if we could make it so you don't crave
anything and you're not hungry it's
gonna make it a lot easier six have
substitute desserts available in your
refrigerator or freezer there's so many
recipes that you can make that mimic the
foods that you shouldn't be eating cakes
and cookies and pies and all you have to
do is consume one of those with your
meal okay not between the meals and that
way you won't feel deprived
number seven no junk food in the house
you're gonna have to talk to your family
your spouse and get their agreement that
you just can't keep the junk food in the
house
and also not in little baskets around
the kitchen and in the living room where
our food is just sitting there all over
the place so we want to get the food
into the cupboards or the refrigerator
and not in front of your face especially
if you get bored at night it's just kind
of like oh let me start eating these
nuts number eight and this is really
important plan out all the meals for the
week and the membership site you get
something called a meal maker and a
couple clicks of your mouse you can
actually select the foods that you want
it generates a whole week of food so you
have a plan of action and you don't end
up going off the program simply because
you're not organized okay so the
organizational step before you just
focus on doing the program is usually
missed by a lot of people so you the key
is planning this thing out for the whole
week so you have the food there it's all
planned and you just follow the plan all
right thanks for watching so if you're
enjoying these videos click Share and
spread the word